wenn ihr durch berlin gehst dann werdet
ihr ab und an diese goldenen steine sind
diese steine nennt man stolpersteine und
sie erinnern an die menschen die in der
zeit des nationalsozialismus verfolgt
und ermordet wurden
in dieser episode möchten wir euch
dieses projekt vorstellen und wir
möchten euch auch ermutigen wenn ihr
nach deutschland oder berlin kommt mehr
darüber herauszufinden
[Musik]
diese stolpersteine sind ein projekt des
künstlers gunter demnig und seit 1992
sind schon über 70.000 stolpersteine in
deutschland und 23 weiteren ländern
verlegt worden
die stolpersteine bilden damit das
größte dezentrale mahnmal der welt wo
findet ihr diese stolpersteine
ihr findet sie überall dort wo menschen
gewohnt haben die in der zeit des
nationalsozialismus verfolgt und
ermordet wurden
in berlin wurden zwischen 1941 und 1945
allein über 55.000 juden deportiert und
umgebracht aber auch politische gegner
sinti und roma homosexuelle und menschen
mit behinderungen wurden in der ns zeit
verfolgt diese drei stolpersteine sehe
ich zum beispiel fast jeden tag
sie erinnern an die jüdische familie
haarzopf die hier in der schönhauser
allee gelebt hat und von hier aus 1943
in das konzentrationslager auschwitz
deportiert wurde
wenn man sich diese geschichten
durchliest dann berührt einen das sehr
stark und das besondere an diesen
stolperstein ist wirklich dass sie am
alltag der menschen ansetzen wenn man in
museen geht oder zu denkmälern geht dann
ist man ganz oft schier überwältigt mit
der größe dieses verbrechens und man
kann sich kaum diese zahlen der nazizeit
vorstellen und der verfolgung und der
ermordung diese stolpersteine setzen sie
sich jedoch daran an im alltag an diese
verbrechen zu erinnern stolperstein
bedeutet ein stein gegen den man
stolpert und so passiert es eigentlich
jeden tag in berlin wenn man spazieren
geht man wird für eine kurze zeit in
diesem moment an
ein teil der geschichte erinnert
[Musik]
diese stolpersteine setzen im alltag von
jedem menschen an und dadurch erinnern
sie uns auch immer wieder dass so ein
verbrechen nicht nur in der
vergangenheit etwas besonderes ist
sondern sie erinnern uns daran wie
alltäglich dass auch zu einer zeit lang
war wenn ich hierher gehe dann stelle
ich mir die frage was haben die nachbarn
gedacht oder gewusst warum haben sie
ihre nachbarn nicht beschützt und was
könnte vielleicht heute passieren kann
so etwas wieder passieren
all das sind fragen die man sich stellt
wenn einem ja wenn man im alltag an
diese verbrechen erinnert wird und wir
möchten euch ermutigen euch auch damit
auseinander zu setzen
die geschichten zu lesen wenn ihr nach
berlin kommt dann schaut euch das an und
lernt mehr über die menschen die hinter
diesen steinen stehen
wenn ihr mehr zu dem projekt erfahren
möchte dann empfehlen wir euch unbedingt
einmal auf der website der stolpersteine
und auch der stolpersteine berlin vorbei
zu schauen
dort könnt ihr tatsächlich alle
geschichten zu den stolpersteinen die
ihr in berlin sieht nachlesen und das
lohnt sich auf jeden fall etwas mehr
darüber zu erfahren welche menschen hier
in der stadt gelebt haben die heute
nicht mehr da sind
danke an euch für das so sehen diese
woche und wir sehen uns nächste woche
wieder
[Musik]